Hey guys, this is Sean, I know in a previous intro I talked about like working out, getting my legs bigger, getting my thighs bigger, getting my arms bigger, just getting everything, like I'm just jumped and packed and jacked and whacked and I was just like, so then after that I thought maybe I'd work on my feet because my feet need to be just as like great as the rest of my body and then after that I thought I'd look around my toes like around my toes and my fingertips and I just thought wow, I'm just kidding, I haven't worked out in years. Welcome to Smart List. Hey, you know, I just want to say something, Jay, I don't know if you know this, but today
you use a heavy bronzer? Today? I know, look at it. Listener, Will's back from the Caribbean. The French Polynesian. Not Polynesian. South Pacific. No, not South Pacific, the French Antilles. Do you put Sun Black on or no? Yes, of course. No, he doesn't. He puts on olive oil is what he does. No, I don't. By the way, I met a lot of really nice, smart list listeners. Really? Oh, in the Caribbean. Yeah, in the Caribbean. And my buddy, Todd, who I met. Oh, sure. Sure. We don't need names, man. Who's Todd from the Caribbean? He's just a guy. Did you compliment him on his first name? He and his wife. He said, he drew a comparison. He said that Todd happens to be the name of your character from Teen
Wolf. Oh, that is true. So, boy, thank him for watching. Limited channels down there on the island. He kept the lights on for you, buddy. So it's just maybe we're playing on the latest. Jason, today's a very special day. It's Sean's birthday. Oh, yes. Thank you. Well, you didn't say anything, but thank you. I wasn't going to mention it at all. Happy birthday, Sean. That's very sweet. Listen, when people get over their sixties, they don't want to celebrate at all, Will. It's true. It's true. Wait, by the way, you guys, I shit you not. Can you read that? Dear Sean, happy birthday from all of us at Garfield Pharmacy. We are wishing you all the best for the coming year. From a pharmacy.
You know, this qualifies as a bit of a flair. It's a crazy pharmacy texted me. Sean, Garfield Pharmacy, did they help you put together that bath you were talking about where you can open the side of it and you can get into it? The one with the door. I thought you were going to say it sits back. Is that your crew? Now, Sean, happy, Will, let's do that fastest happy birthday to you song ever. Happy birthday to you. Happy birthday to you. Happy birthday to you. Happy birthday to you, Sean. Happy birthday to you. Sean, you are an absolute, I will say this. You're an incredible friend. Jason, you know this. There have been so many times, I'm not surprised, but there have been so many awesome times I can think of within
the last month where things were going on and you just reach out in a way that a lot of other people would feel like, well, I'll just let them kind of marinate. And you just reach out and call and go, Hey, are you okay? Yeah. And Sean, I love you for it. I love you guys. I love you too. Yeah. I did that with you too, Jay. I do that. I do that because I love you guys more than anything. Listener, if you ever get the chance to be friends with Sean Hayes, it's the best. I highly recommend it. It's the trial. Do a trial first. And by the way, but now we mentioned we love Sean. We love you so much. But there are people who don't obviously one of the, one of the people is scavo obviously because I don't
know what's going on. Or did you get a fight with his scissors or him? I know. Look at it. That's great. That's what that's what's coming for me on Wednesday. Really? Finally going to cut. Yeah. For folks who can't see, I've got a, I've got a whole head of hair that's 30 pounds of hair. Are you, when are you done? Oh, I just finished. I was doing a job where I had to play a fellow that was living in 1984. It's a 1984 thing. And so all this feathering was really appropriate. Now it's not. And so it's coming down on Wednesday. But what was the excuse before you got the part? Exactly. Yeah. Cause it was long for a minute. Yeah. But then I was about to cut it and then didn't cause I got
this job. I actually think it looks cool along. Thank you. Wait, really fast, super fast, quick birthday story from when I was like, I don't know, 22. My mom thought it'd be so great to put instead of candles on a cake, she put sparklers, like 20 of them. I could like that. Not realizing that sparklers, you know, our fireworks basically, and they don't blow out. And so she lit all of them and the whole fucking thing like lit up, caught fire. And then she's cutting. And then after she put it all out, she's, you know, she's like happy birthday and there's fucking fireworks all over. You mess around with fireworks. You lose an eye. Well, that's nice, man. And then she cut the cake and it tasted like sulfur.
Nothing on eye, nothing on the eye joke at all. Maybe Tracy's laughing. Put an eye out. You know who likes to laugh. Oh, what a great segue. What a great. Hey, by the way, does anybody work a segue better than me? Double entendre. Double entendre. Double entendre. Okay. Let me tell you something. Let me tell you something. This guy. This guy. Can I tell you something about this guy? Here's something you didn't know about this guy because you both know this country. Things I don't know. Here's something. His parents. Yeah. His parents, couple of nice folks, or both satellite engineers, satellite engineers, try engineers one more time. Still wrong. Worked on engineers, engineers. Worked on a Minuteman nuclear missile guidance
system. Wow. Apollo lunar module guidance system. The science of the ground station of the Hubble space telescope. Things like of this nature. And then this person is about he plays soccer. Let's book the parents. How about that? Okay. Hang on a second. And then this person, you would know them. No way he's going to be as interesting. Let me think about how you're going to know this person. You might know this person from some of these. Some of the. Wow. Take your time. Real perfect. I'm just trying to think of some of the things you would know them from picket fences, maybe golden palace. These are appearances. Northern exposure. X files. Oh, maybe not. Maybe from the jackal. No, enemy of the state. You're
saving the real one for later. Water world. Demolition man. No, you'd probably know this person more from shallow howl, not to liberate tenacious deed. The picket nest, and school rocket. Mr. Jack. Look at that face. It's gorgeous. I've just been back here behind my little toilet paper hiding spot. Are you in the toilet right now? Well, your producers said I have to hide myself with like something and I don't have a handkerchief or anything. So I just. You usually have a hanky your old school like that. You've got like an old school hanky on you all the time. And he offers it to people who are crying, even though it's not stained. Quick plug. My buddy Colin Hanks has a handkerchief company called Hanks kerchief.
Not true. Is that true? 100% true. Check it out. As I have a mold removal company called adjacent abatement that I want to send you say everybody. Listen, Jack, by the way, at any point, I love it so much at any point. If you want to just do a little side, like a little quick plug ski for friends, I'm down with it. I hated having that right out of the gate, but I couldn't not talk about my you talked handkerchiefs and like that's that's the first place I go. Now, first of all, we got two J.B.s here for the first time. I mean, this is my God, right? Let's go with let's go with Jack. I mean, it's not a better name than Jack. You be J.B. today. Oh, you want to hold on to J.B.? Were you ever Jack? Were
you ever a John? What? No. In fact, my real name is Thomas. No, it's not Thomas black back up a second. Is it really Sean? Where are you coming from? Thomas Jacob, right, Jack? That's right. Thomas Jacob black. So if I wanted to go short for Jacob, it would have been Jake black. You don't want to have been good for you. Well, TJ. TJ black. TJ. Yeah, not bad. Different career. So I can understand if his name was Henry, you'd ask him if he was ever Hank, but is our Jack's ever John? Yes. Yeah, of course. That's where Jack comes from. Lots of Johns and Jonathan's are John F. Kennedy. Thank you. Don't scream at me. Now, Jack, I got the J.B. and I never asked for it. Did you ever ask for J.B.? I
didn't know. You don't you're not. It's not cool to ask for your nickname. That's not the way it's supposed to go. Exactly. But then, but I'm afraid people think that I have asked for it when somebody when somebody calls me that because it sounds like J.B., you know, like I'm some sort of a power figure or authority. That's like a boss. But you can't ask your nickname. Let's ask pants wetter. Sean, sorry. Yeah. What are you? What are you? I didn't have to ask for that. No. Jack, Jack, I can't believe it's taken us this long to have you here. I know. We can't make his deal. We can't make his deal. I feel like. It's such a layup that you would be, we just, I adore you and just think you're the freaking greatest
and I just can't believe it's taken forever, man. I'll second that. Well, the feeling is muc. I'm a huge fan of all three of you individually and collectively. Do you remember, do you remember when we all used to play poker at Kyle's house together? Yes. Yes. We all partied over at Kyle Gass's house to play poker. Kyle Gass is my partner in Tenacious D. That's right. But now, are you still playing cards and music with Kyle Gass, with the K-Jerrific? I am playing music with Kyle Gass. We're still touring and we got a very big project coming up that I can't really tell you anything about, but we got a concept album coming down the pike. A one more sip of that morning coffee there and then you'll feel like telling us.
I haven't had any. Does it seem like I'm amped and jazzed? No, no. I was trying to make a booze joke, you know, and you say, have one more sip of that drink and then you'll tell me. All right. Well, maybe later. Maybe we'll earn it at the end of the session here. So maybe we'll earn it. Maybe we'll gain your confidence, but I will say this. So, Jack, just so we can get back to Cage for a second for one sec, Kyle Gass in his poker game. First of all, what are the odds that he's in a sleeveless sweatshirt right now? Very high. That's his whole thing. That's his loose football practice shorts. Can I tell you something? And slides. He's always about the comfort. So Jack's partner, Kyle Gass,
who he just alluded to in his partner in Tenacious D, and they made a number of records and movies and the TV show for a few years, all of it. One time, so we all played in this poker game. I forget who was our first entree into the game, but it was a Tuesday night game. You used to play and then we came into it a little bit later and then we brought, and then Richter was in it and Sean was in it. I remember Sean came in the first night, won a bunch and there was like, I got to go home guys. And everybody's like, you're not going bucking the handyman. The Walsh brothers were not having that. No. And we had Matt Walsh and, you know, we had a Patti Walsh and we had everybody. Right. So then we played in that for a couple of years
and there was a lot of dough was exchanged back and forth in some, some fireworks here and there. And Kage used to have the clown car and then he had the celebrity clown car. Literally, remember you had that car and you put people in it. But Jack, what I was getting to was, I remember going to, you were hosting SNL once and Kage was coming. And so he said, and I was going back to New York cause Amy was still on the show at the time. And he's like, what fight are you? I go, I'm going to take the red eye on Friday night. He goes, I'll come on the same flight. I'll meet you at LAX. I go, great. So I text him with or whatever I go, I'll meet you at the gate and Kage shows up at the gate and he's in his sleeveless sweatshirt
in shorts and flips. And he's got every single glossy celeb rag in a pile. And I go, and I go, Kage, what are you doing? Get away from me, man. What are you, what are you doing? Yeah. He likes reading those. He loves to read up on the celebs, on the latest got the hot goss. Now are you guys still playing cards at all, Jack? No, I haven't been playing with, with Kage. We haven't been playing cards. I miss it. And once in a while, you know, whenever there's like a charity poker game, I like to jump in there because I do love it. But I do find that when I lose inevitably, it does hurt. It excruciate, there's an excruciating pain and regret that lasts for days.
Or it's like, God dang it. If I would have just, you know what I did? I didn't have the balls to call. Why didn't I just call? I had queens. And it'll stick with me and I'll feel like an idiot. And then when I get up from the table, like, all right, guys, hope everyone had a good, good, good time. And as I'm leaving, I can see in their eyes, they just have this poison of like, yes, we beat you. We made you a fool. And, and I hate everyone. And the chips are usually sitting in front of Kyle. And yet I do always still feel that pull to get back in the game. Cause it's kind of, it's fun. It's a good place to watch a Laker game, kind of out the side of one eye. And, or Kyle's house. Yeah. Yeah, we should do it again. We should do it again. So, so Jack,
this one, I don't know. So you started, it says here, if you look on your bio, anybody can look this up. Anybody who's got access to the internet, you, your first thing you did, you did a commercial for a vid game way back in the day, way back in the day. Really? Yeah. What was the inclination? How did that, what was the thing? You grew up in Santa, you were born in Santa Monica, but you grew up a little south of Santa Monica. Permosa beach. Permosa beach. Shout out. What was the moment? Like, what was the thing that you were like, I'm going to go out for this video game commercial? Like, how did you get, how did your path? Well, I'm sure it was just whatever gig was available. You know how it started? Yeah. It started at a Passover Seder. We went over to a friend's house,
family friend, and she was a Holocaust survivor and a really cool lady, mama of the house. And we had our Passover Seder, good Jewish dinden, religious kind of. And then after that, she was like, now it's time for everybody to come to the living room. We're going to play the freeze game. And I said, the freeze game. And I was like eight years old. And it was an improvisational game created by the great Viola Spolan. Jason, I heard you earlier saying yes, Anne. So you're familiar with the dark arts of improvisation. And it's basically just like two people get up on the stage with a living room floor, whatever, what have you. And they'll just start doing a scene. They'll make it up like, okay, we're two butter churners and they'll be churning butter and go,
oh, the churning is so hard. I'm so sweaty. Oh, the sweat is going into the butter. And then anyone in the audience can go freeze. And then they have to stay frozen like they're churning butter. And then you go up and you tap one of them on the shoulder and they leave. And then you take their body position and then you can change it to like, oh, I'm going to murderize the guy. And now you're a boxer who's like punching you. And I played that and I caught the fever so hard because my eight year old like performance instincts kicked in. And I was already kind of a ham class clown. That's what I was going to say. Were you already kind of in that, in that space, like with your friends and at school and shit? Yeah. I mean, I was,
I was starved for laughs. I loved getting yucks. Uh-huh. And it was the sweet manna from heaven. And so, so then my parents divorced. This is, I'm not good at telling stories. No, this is a good thing. I'm so longer than you want to know that you can get into a cry right here. By the way, this is short for Bateman. This is, if you were Bateman, this would be considered short. So go ahead. I don't think I'm going to cry, but my parents divorced. What was that like, Jack? And then, um, I was still kind of like doing stuff. Like I was really into weird Al Yankovic and Hermosa Beach going to school. We would do different songs from, from the Dr. Demento show in front of the classroom, me and some of my friends. And then my, my mom started
dating this, this dude, David Katz, my stepdad. And he was like, a really creative guy. And he's like, Jack, Jack is very talented. He should be doing this. I was like, I do want to do this. I want to be on TV. And there was a kid in my class in Hermosa Beach. I was so jealous of him. He was in a movie called Real Life by the incredible genius known as Albert Brooks. Albert Brooks. Yes. Not Albert Einstein. His real name changed to Brooks. Was Charles Groden in that? Yes. Yes. He played the dad of the family. And the whole family is like, Oh, did he play the dad? No, I don't remember who played who. This isn't a Stiller's favorite movie. I think it might be because it is a great movie. And anyway, so this little punk was in it.
This punk was in it. He played the son. He didn't have a big part, but I just was like, Oh, I want what he has. How did he get that to do? How do you do it? And my stepfather thinks it's easy. You go on the auditions, you go and you do. It takes a picture of yourself. And I was like, that, will you take me? And he was like, Yes. No way. And my stepfather drove me around town and I auditioned for all of the commercials and all the things for like a year. I got an agent, the Jack Rose agency. I was at Jack Rose. You were at Jack Rose. I was at Jack Rose. It was also Jack Rose's Dorothy Dayotus. We probably bumped into each other like a hundred times at auditions. Was Dorothy Dayotus also on the door? I don't remember. Did you book right away, Jack?
No. I went on a few. I booked pretty quick though. It wasn't the first one, but one of the early ones, I was like 12 years old. Yeah. It was the video game commercial you're talking about. It was for Activision for Atari. It was called Pitfall. Yeah. I love that. And I remember the audition. I went in there and I auditioned my ass off and they were like, can you do it like you're really cocky, like you're real cocksure yourself? Not a problem. It was perfect because that's like, that was my go-to acting character thing is being super confident, overconfident. And I just crushed it and I left the audition high. That was the thing. Those auditions, those were like drugs to me because it felt so good to like nail it. It didn't
even matter if I got the part or not. If I got them laughing, I was like, I love life. You still get that charge, right? When you get a laugh or you're in front of an audience or a camera or something, right? I still get a charge if I feel like a job well done. Yeah. Nice. What about if you make your kids laugh? Is it an audience of one plenty big? Dude, if I can make my kids laugh, that's actually the top of the heap and it's tough. They are a tough audience because I'm so embarrassing to them. That's not true. How old are they now? They're now 13 and 15. Oh, that's a tough audience. Actually, sorry. My boy just had a birthday, 14 and 15. I got a 15-year-old and she just, you got to have, your shit's got to be tight, worked on and bulletproof,
but if you're going to get even a grin out of her, you know, you can't be workshopping material in front of her. Go ahead, Sean. I was just saying, Jason's kid, Maple, I just have to shop and go, hey, and she laughs. Yeah, she's a little bit easier, but she'll get tough. But the 15-year-old audience, but also Sean's the funniest of all of us. Can we just admit it? So Sean's got it. He's also the best host. He's got the nominations to prove it. Oh yeah, he got nominated for best host. Wait, Jack, I want to know. I'm trying to talk over at Sean. This is something you should really revel in. Here's how desperate for last, in Mitchell Roberts and I, the great Mitchell Roberts, great rest development, he and I would be writing stuff and we'd be at his house
and then he'd be like, we need to go to Starbucks because we'd be in his office writing all day and we just needed to go and do, because we didn't have an audience anymore. We were sick of each other and we thought like the barista or whoever's in line next to us could probably use some exposure to what we got going on. And we will be right back. And now, back to the show. Jack, I want to ask you about those amazing Instagram things you do because I laugh so fucking hard at those and they seem like they take weeks to film. The fucking production value. The energy and the effort that goes into them. I want to see these. Thank you. They're so funny. Thank you for noticing. Yeah, I mean, you're in your superhero speedos and you're running around like doing superhero things.
Like what goes into those and why do you do them? Is it fun to do it? Well, I was just sort of coming up with things to do during pandemic times. I was going stir crazy like everybody and I had that you know, that hunger that we talked about earlier where I needed attention. And now it's also like two birds with one stone. The world needs a laugh. Let's see if we can cook something up. So I called up my social media guru, Taylor Stevens. Shout out. Shout out. And I said, let's uh, you know what? I'm feeling like I need to do something with this wop dance. The kids are going crazy. It's the latest thing that everyone's trying to do their version of the wop dance. Can you tell Granddad Bateman what that is? The wop dance, it's wet ass pussy. Okay.
And it was a huge hit. It was a colossal hit. So I got in my speedo and I just had my friend spray me with a garden hose and I did my dance and it got a good Jillian likes and views. And then I was off to the races and I was like, okay, next I'm going to suit up as a Spider-Man because Spider-Man was about to come out. One of those Spider-Man's was coming out or something. There was some reason and I suited up and I did some more dancing and then I just couldn't stop. It was like a runaway freight train. It was so good. Nobody wanted you to stop. It was hysterical. No one is a better performer than you, Jack. No. I mean, what about you closing out the end of High Fidelity? What was that song you sang on the stage? That was uh, I've been really trying. Oh, God.
Let's get it on. I just don't think there's a better performance of any song by any performer than any medium than that. Well, that was my big break, that, that movie. Was it? That was, well, you had done, yeah, so I was going to get into that. So that was your, that was the thing that you had done a bunch of stuff. First of all, I want to kind of get into this a little bit. So backing up, you, you had started, did you engage me doing the Actors Gang? Is that how you guys? Yep. What was the genesis of the Actors Gang? Walk us through that a little bit. Well, the Actors Gang is like a punk rock theater group from Los Angeles in the 80s. They started Tim Robbins, John Cusack, that whole crew. And if you were a young actor in the 80s in LA,
that was the sweet spot. You wanted to be in the Actors Gang. Well, that, that was my feeling anyway. I don't know, Jason, were you even aware of them or care about that world? I was, I stayed away from gangs a lot, but I wasn't a real gang. I mean, there was no violence. It was, they sound pretty hard. Actors Gang sounds like the softest gang. No, I was busy. Improbuted death. I was reading for Golden Grams commercials and Honey Nut Cheerios and whatnot. Yeah. Yeah. But I would have, I would have loved to have gotten, gotten some gang tats on me from the Actors. They were doing a lot of like political theater and, and they had a cool style that they used the, Stanislavski? No, it was, it was Comedia dell'arte, more like. Sure.
You know, they get all made up in the white face and a lot of presentation looking out into the audience. And anyways, I went to see them when I was like 16 years old. I was in high school and I went to see their production of Freaks. And who is in there? Kyle Gass was one of the actors, Ned Bellamy, Lee Ehrenberg, all of the, all the great Actors Gangers. And I was just sort of like a psycho fan of the gang. I wanted in. It was like they were the chili peppers. I just wanted to be in their world. I wanted to be in a production. So I would go to see the shows and then I would hang out and, and I had a connection, a friend of mine, Bob White, who was a teacher at my school, Crossroads High School. Yeah, the professor. He was a technical theater and also a writer for a
lot of the shows at Actors Gang. Wait, wait, wait, Jack, Jack, it should be noted the professor, Bob White, also part of the, our poker game. We all know Bob. Yes, the professor, a very big chip collector himself. Yeah, very big. So he got me a part in a show called The Big Show. And then I got another part in Carnage when we went to Edinburgh Theater Festival. Whoa. And things were cooking with gas. And then we took it to New York, to the Joe Papps Public Theater. Come on. They're in the park. And we got just murdered. The reviews were so, it didn't even matter the reviews. It was one review. It was like, this guy, this Hollywood schmoo, Tim Robbins, comes to New York with his Hollywood crap and tries to tell me that this is real theater. That's not word for word
at all. It was an expertly written, just hatchet job. And it was such a bad review that I just laughed. I just thought this is actually hilarious because you, if you're going to get a bad review, you want it to be the worst review of all time. Yeah, you want it well written. Yeah. Hey, Will, at the beginning when you introed Jack, was that really true about his parents? You made that a lot. I think that's true, right, Jack? My parents are much more interesting than me. It is. No, no, but I mean, like all that, what were they? My parents were aerospace engineers. That's crazy, both of them. Yeah. And my mom was a real trailblazer, one of the first women to be successful in that field and climb the ladder and kick a lot of ass. I don't really understand
what they did because I did not inherit their mathematical genius. That's amazing though. That's wild. But yeah, my mom worked on Apollo missions, specifically Apollo 13. She was responsible for the abort guidance system that actually saved some astronauts' lives. Well, that's insane. Yeah, they were going to die, except they were like, what's this button? Judith Cohen abort guidance system button. I don't know what happened. Something happened and she was part of the reason why they survived. And they came and visited her at the office after the whole mission a few months later to say, just wanted to thank you, Mrs. Cohen, for saving our lives. That's crazy. Did you have any desire at all to get into some sort of a science world there?
No. I love science fiction. I do, too. I love it. I live for it. 2001 Space Odyssey. Love it. Great book. Arthur C. Clark. I do have a fascination for astronomy and for that world, but I don't, I understand that I don't have what it takes to actually succeed in that field. Don't you say that? Well, no. For instance, I've tried to read that book A Brief History of Time. Yes. It's not so brief. Couldn't make it past the first 10 pages. It should be more brief. I don't understand it. Yeah. And then I was like, wait, you know what? They made a movie out of that book, A Brief History of Time. I'll just watch that. Yeah. I couldn't understand the movie. Wait, what, Jack? Did you see Ex Machina?
Ex Machina. Great movie. Isn't that the best? One of the best movies ever. Jack, have you ever done a science fiction? It's like Stanley Kubrick came back out of the grave and directed that kind of. Yeah. Do you know what I mean? That's a great movie. He had a lot of Kubrick-y science fiction. I would say Jumanji. Jumanji is sound science fiction. That is science fiction. The TV, you know, listen, you know, things happen. How else would you explain it, Will? I don't know, but no, but like a pure science fiction, Jack, have you ever done like something like a, I don't know, it's maybe more to, would you want to do like an aliens-y type thing or
something like that? Would that get you going? Dude, you know, I love aliens. Aliens is a good example of something I feel like I could jump in because it was great science fiction. But then Bill Paxton came in and just crushed that comedic role. Yeah. We're toast, man. Amen. Yeah. That's right. Another great science fiction comedy he was in. Weird science. Weird science. And then he got turned into, he got turned into Jabba the Hutt. That's where Jabba the Hutt started. You know, that's a prequel. Jabba the Hutt. Did you know that? No. Yeah. That's where Jabba the Hutt starts. Weird science. That's where it was. He gets turned into Jabba, and then, you know, thousands of years later, Jabba is up on that planet. That's from, that's
Star Wars canon. Huh. Yeah. But that is the thing. You want to find that thing where it's science fiction, but it's funny. And sometimes it works. It's kind of rare, though, but one that comes to mind. What was that rad one where they were all actors, but then they... Galaxy Quest. Galaxy Quest. Amazing. Speaking of actors getting into trouble, Tropic Thunder is just, is and will always be one of my favorite movies of all time. It is one of the things one could do today, I would imagine. Yeah. I'm going to say thank you. Yeah, you should. Even though I can't really take credit for it, but I was in it, and I did love being in it. You were a lot in it and a big, big, big part of how great that movie was. But, Jack, everybody knows you have this incredible voice. You know,
you really do have an unbelievable singing voice. What about a musical movie? Has anybody approached you about doing a movie musical? Like, you would have been great into the woods. I got it. Redo Flash Gordon. Yeah. Right? Remember Flash Gordon with the Queen soundtrack of Rock Opera? Yeah. Come on, bro. Oh, man. Yeah, I love that. Love Queen. Love Flash Gordon. Fold it all together. Love to see you. It's got the spandex outfits you like to wear on the gram. The insta. What's it called? I would like to be that character that was like, yeah. He was like, oh, yeah. The dude that looked like he was from Road Warrior. I saw that in the theater. Did you guys see that in the theater? I did. Yeah, we're that old. What was that guy's name? The blonde guy that was
Flash Gordon? Oh, yeah. What was that guy? I don't, I think. Wait, Jack, tell me about, I remember reading about you completely tearing your ankle apart on The Last Conan show. You were supposed to do The Last Conan. Yes. What was the bit that made it happen and like, what was the story? All I know is that you hurt your ankle. Okay, so that was a weird one because I was called up to do the final episode of the Conan farewell show, which is an honor. You know, we love us some Conan. You can't say no to something like that because you gotta love Conan and all the years he's been awesome. I was like, yes. But then I immediately started getting nervous. What am I going to do? It's got to be something special. It's got to be super funny. And they came up with a really
funny idea. I thought where I come out, I'm singing a song to Conan. I'm getting really into it. I'm getting physical. I'm taking off my clothes. And then I injure myself. I like, my Achilles. And I go down and then paramedics come and they take me out. I'm sorry. I'm sorry. Oh, God. This is all the bed. And they take me out to the ambulance. And then I say, no, stop the ambulance. And I burst out of the back doors and I come running back. I can't let you down Conan. And I come back in, I burst in and the crowd roars and I finished the song. And it was going to be great. But then when we were doing a pre-tape, because you can't do all of that live, you have to have the you have to cut the carrying me out to the ambulance and the running back into the theater
done the day before. Right. The rest of it would be live though. That's right. So on the running out of the ambulance back into Largo Theater, I stepped, I was running with some like funny shoes and you blew a tire in my speedo. So it was already really humiliating. I stepped on like an uneven piece of sidewalk and they even had to tape there to let idiots know, be careful because it's uneven here. And I rolled the ankle and I heard a pop and I was like, and I went down for real. And it was so surreal because it was so much like what the bit we were going to do. Yeah, it's very meta. I injured myself doing the bit. And they thought you were still doing the bit? No, they knew that's not where he's supposed to. Conan came running out and everyone was like, oh
God. And he tripped. The crew tripped. Yeah. And then the people, Conan was like, there's the ambulance. Come on guys, come out and they're like, we're not paramedics, we're actors. We were hired. We move on background. Is this a cut? Are we cutting? Are we in grace right now? We're in lunch. There was a lot of confusion. Someone made a quick run to get me some ice. I got the MRI and it was definitely wrecked. And they were like, yeah, you're going to have to take a few months off. And I was like, how long did it take to heal? I mean, to be honest with you, it's still not a hondo percent. Right. I don't know if it'll ever be like obviously still in litigation, Sean. Yeah. What is the number you're seeking from Conan Produce? It still hurts. I get it.
It's part of the one of the risks of the game. I don't want to go suing. I don't think I am a lawyer. I would bury Conan in lawyers. Was the appearance still kind of somewhat salvaged? Yes. So I say to the doctor later that day, but can I go and just sing? He's like, yeah, you can't dance. You can't do any of the physical stuff you're going to do. But you can sing just to wear the boot. So I wore the boot and I showed up and it was very heroic. I actually ended up being, I think, better than what it was going to be. Did they show the part of you rolling the ankle as part of the pit? No. Oh, they showed up. But we talked about it. Now, talk to me about those kids. Now, those kids are at 14 and 15, speaking from my own experience, as early as this morning,
I was talking to my 15-year-old about next year, we got to start looking at colleges. Are you prepared? Are you and the baby mama prepared for the empty nesting that's going to start? No. I'm not going to do well with that. I know it. Have you already started separating from your children just to preserve your own emotional well-being? I've already started atrophying all of my love and affection for my children because I'm trying to protect myself. That's how you do it, right? Atrophy the love. Yeah, that's how he thinks. He did that at birth, right? When you were in the labor. Well, I picked up the kid, I cut the cord, I gave him a little piece of labor. He was like, these kids are going to leave me. Like everything else in my life,
it's going to leave me. I've got to start pulling away now. I think we are trying to do the opposite. We're jonesing for the time like three years ago when they loved us way more. But once they hit those teen years, that separation, they're taking care of that. They're taking care of the atrophy. They're like, oh, you guys are so embarrassing. Just stay away from us. I don't want to talk to you. Right. It's part of their growing up is to emancipate themselves from their parents. Yeah. You know, they're doing well. I'm glad they like going to school because I was the worst and I thought if they take after me, they're going to sleep through school. Did you do any additional voluntary school, college? I did some Hebrew school, but it wasn't really voluntary. My parents
forced me to do it until I got my bar mitzvah at 13. I was like, I'm done. And they're like, no, but you can continue to study. No. Yeah. So there was no college for you. I went to UCLA. And I was a theater major and I was there for like a year and a half, but really just because my dad wanted me to get a degree. And I dropped out and I ran away with the actor's gang. Dude, UCLA is not an invite. They just throw out. No, it's tough. You probably had some good numbers getting in there. It was very competitive, but yeah, I had some decent numbers. It wasn't as competitive as it is now. In 89, 88, 89, you could get in there with, you didn't need straight A's. And maybe I pulled a couple strings. Maybe I got a little help. How excited was David Katz
that he was proved right? This is the talent scout, David Katz, aka your stepdad. How stoked was he when it really started to pan out was he's just like, look how good young Jack is doing. Yes. But also what was your relationship like? What an awesome thing that he encouraged you. Yes. Recognize that that was something that was a positive. Yes. And he encouraged you. And then you really made it your life. And how did that affect your relationship with him? All that stuff. Yeah, very proud. And definitely has been a great touchstone and person to talk to all throughout my career, just to share with him like, well, now this is happening. And oh, I got an audition for this. And you know, I'll ask him his advice and he gets a kick out of it. And he also writes,
you know, he wants to get that going too. And I feel like, God, he got me going. I got to get him going. I got him to write a sci-fi thing. You know what's funny? You say that because my dad in the last couple of years, during the pandemic, my dad wrote a book and a great book. What's the name of it, Willie? It's called Bean Fate. And it just came out in Canada. What's it called? Bean, like a bean, like a jelly bean fate. It's a play on a word of BFA and whatever, bunch of things, but it's French. But it's not a French book, but he wrote it. It's based on a true story and about these, these sort of guys, you know, in the liquor business during prohibition and stuff. And it's a sort of like a based on true events. My dad wrote a book over the pandemic.
It was called I'm out of here. For real? No. Well, well, sorry, go ahead. It's okay. We'll can cut that out. Thanks, Sean. I'm going to talk to you. Just you have an extra time after the session. But I'm really proud of my dad. He wrote this book. And in the same way, I'm really psyched that he did that at this age. You know, he's, he's getting on and that is amazing. He actually did it and he found a publisher and he just got published and, and it's pretty cool. And I think that I'm sure in the same way you feel that about David, like they're wanting to encourage him to, I think it's pretty, pretty rad. Yeah. Well, he's super creative and funny too. I think he's a real character. You could tell by my impersonation of him earlier that he's got, he's got some magic
sauce. And I actually tried to get him going. He had an idea because he loves to Uber and all through pandemic times, he was Ubering everywhere. And I got him an Uber account. So I'm like, go crazy. Do it. Excel Uber. What a son. And he does the, and he says, I hate it. I was like, I had, I had the most incredible conversation with this, this, this painter. And I was like, this is great. And he's like, I have an idea for an Uber. I should do an Uber commercial. And I was like, I'm on it. And so we went and we directed, we, we got cameras. We got some Uber drivers that he became friends with and we put like cameras in the Ubers and, and had him go all around town. No way. In Ubers and like just talking with people and having conversations.
And I swear it was the funniest little thing. It was called come Uber with me. And you would get in the Uber with David Katzen. Did Uber see this? It was one of the funniest. Well, of course, that was the whole point. We were going to make this and we sent it to Uber. And they were like, hard pass. We're not going to do this. And also you're not allowed to show this to anyone. Oh, wow. No way. Wow. I was kind of lame. But I felt like they were being so short-sighted because they, they needed at the time, like a little humanistic, humanizing business. But for whatever reason, you know, David, when he talks with people, he doesn't really have a filter and he'll say some inappropriate things, but that's where the funny comedy happens. He says stuff, you know,
that maybe culturally he'll cross boundaries. You're not supposed to talk about things with people. But I think that he's a super star. What was that show, Taxicab Confessions? Yes. Wasn't that, that was on HBO, I think? HBO, yeah, wasn't that great? Yeah. Yeah, why don't they still do that? You know, a friend of mine was on it and he was wasted. And it was him and like two other gay guys in the back seat. And they were cleaning out. They're like, girl, like they were so over the top making fun of every single person in the world. And then they were plowed so drunk and they got out and they go, we're HBO's Taxicab Confessions. Would you sign this release form? And my friend,
even though he was plowed drunk, had to wear it with all to be like, no, I would not sign in that. I would not sign. I was going to ask that question. Like, how did they, do they tell you before you get in or do they tell you after? They must tell you after, yeah. There must be so many great episodes where the drunk person didn't sign the thing. Only incredible episodes would be those, right? Where he's like, oh, no, no, no, no, no. No one's ever going to see that. Dude, didn't Todd Phillips drive a cab on Taxicab Confessions? That sounds familiar. That was one of his early gigs. No. Yeah. Yeah, yeah, that sounds familiar. You know who else? Danny Sullivan used to be a New York
Taxicab driver. And these people are for Tracy. They are Todd Phillips and Danny Sullivan are director, right? Well, Danny Sullivan was an IndyCar driver, but Todd Phillips was a director. Yes, is a director. Good director. Great director. And now a word from our sponsor. All right, back to the show. Jack, what's coming up for you that you're excited about? Like any projects that you're working on that are... Well, Jack's got this new, I want to say, because he's not going to do his own plug ski, so I'm going to do it. Jack's got this Kung Fu Panda series that's coming. No way. No way. Where? Really? It's going to be on Netflix. Oh, great. Thank you for bringing that up. You're right.
I'm not a real plugger. I've got other people's handkerchiefs, but it's back to the panda. And it's funny because it came up in pandemic times. Panda. Panda. There must be a way to connect those, but... Yeah, voice work works great during the pandemic. That's how this thing got started. Oh, dude. Yeah, no kidding, because I was going through crazy as it's been established. And Netflix was like, hey, we're taking over your old gig, the Kung Fu Panda. And we know that you never do the TV show. They got a sound alike to do that. But would you want to do it now that we're doing it? And I was like, yes, I want it just because I just wanted some like... I wanted some rad pandemic times, like gigs to keep my sanity. Yeah, of course. And do you do it there
in the little... In the room you're doing this? Exactly. This is where I do everything, by the way. It's a real boring nondescript background, but this is John Spiker's studio. He's also a tenacious D bass player and does all of our production on our last few albums. No way. And so it sounds so good here. I was like, oh, I just want to do all my interviews here too. It's the best, right? Are you one of those actors? Like, do you panic if you're not working and and then you start maybe writing something and looking for something? Or are you like, good, you know what? I'll wait for it to come. He already answered you, dude. I wouldn't even let you finish. Yes, the panic is real. I think that's an inherent part of being an actor or an
entertainer. Like, what is the next gig? And all the whole time I'm working on a gig, I'm thinking, God, when is it over? I just want my Google Calendar to be empty. But then once you get there, and the Google Calendar is empty, it's terrifying. Because it's like, wait, I think it might be over. Never goes away. Dude, I do the exact same thing where I just I'm like, I just can I just have like five days where there's nothing to fucking do blah, blah, blah. And then you wake up on that first day of the five and you're like, where's all this stuff? I was like, wait, wait, Jack, I want to ask you because we were talking about HBO before and stuff. How did Tenacious D, the show, how did that start? Obviously, you engage in each other. But what was the genesis of that?
I love the D. Thank you. I just want that as a sound. But I want people to take that me saying I love the D. And the D stands for the D stands for defense. But now it definitely sounds like it stands for dick. Yeah. Love the D defense. Yes, it didn't. No one was saying the D back when we first started Tenacious D. That that wasn't a thing until the late 2000s. Yeah. But anyway, it started, I was in the actors gang. And me and Kyle were both sort of musical people in that world. And, and we sort of started our own splinter group. I just went over to his house all the time. We smoked a bunch of weed and, and jammed. And we're just sort of best friends. And then we were, we wanted to write the best song in the world and call it the best song in the world.
And we just thought that was so dumb and so funny. And we worked on it for a while and it wasn't quite gelling. The concept was wrong. And then we're like, oh, wait, and it clicked. We forgot the best song in the world. We did write it, but we weren't recording because we're stoners. And we're so mad. But you know, let's just write. So the song is a lament. We forgot. It's a, it's a called a tribute. It's called tribute to the greatest song in the world because we forgot it. And that to this day is still our flagship song. It was like, back when we only had one song and it was tribute, we've been chasing the dragon ever since. Isn't that what the concept of the film was too? Or am I, am I kind of mad? Yes, right? The pick of destiny was, was definitely a greatest song
in the world centric, but that was actually more about Satan's tooth that was turned into a guitar pick. That is my pride. Enjoy that film because that's the only movie I've ever written. And, and even though it was a huge box office bomb, I couldn't have been more proud of it. And I, I did feel like it was the best movie ever made. Is writing the hardest thing you've ever done? It was the most satisfying and most fun. And I, that was the biggest tragedy is that the movie wasn't a huge hit because if it was a huge hit, I would have gone straight into the next thing that I would have written. Right. But yeah. Yeah. But I mean, talk to our buddy, Justin Thoreau, you know, he writes Tropic Thunder and he's, you know, he's not, he's not like dying to write,
you know, script after script after script, you know, it doesn't automatically just kind of make you Patty Chayevsky. That's true. But you know, we, we, uh, we did that and, um, take your time, man. Yeah. Because now, now I'm lost. Watch this guys. Watch this. I can't even remember where we started. When you were very, well, that was it. That was the first time the first, no, the first time I met tribute. Oh, but, oh, but anyway, we had our one song tribute that we wrote. Yeah. And we went and played our one song, a friend of ours said, Hey, will you come open for me in downtown LA at a little club called Al's Bar. And we're like, yeah, it was a buddy of mine, Steve Moramarko gave us our big break at some like rat infested bar.
And there's 12 people in the audience, but they were kind of cool drunk hipsters and, and we rocked tribute and we rocked so hard, like we put all of our guts into it. And one of the drunk hipsters is the Lord was looking down upon us. David Cross just happened to be there. That's what I thought. And he was like, you guys are really funny, man. Um, I'm David Cross. And, uh, did he hold for applause after he said that? No. I've seen him do that. I'm David Cross. He just is like, um, I have a comedy thing that I'm, I just started with my friend Bob Odenkirk. We do a Mr. Show. Will you guys come down and open for us, play that song? And we're like, yes. And we didn't have any idea who he was.
And we didn't know about the Ben Stiller show or any of that stuff where he came from. We were just like, we got another gig. It didn't matter what it was. It could have gas up the van. And so that is really what led to the beginning of Tenacious D because Bob and David gave us a sweet slot. And when they went to HBO to do Mr. Show, they brought us along and made us the little appetizer for their show. And that changed everything. And really, that's how I got high fidelity. Then that, that's where school of rock came from. So it's a big, there was a big turning point in my career. Have you sent David a muffin basket or never even sent him? Yeah, nothing. He got nothing in return. But, but now I'm giving him a loving shout out. That's a pretty good,
yeah. They're with Hermosa Beach and Hankies. Yeah. But, but this is like, this is like, but it goes to show how fucking small all that, how connected David sees you. He's drunk at a bar. David being drunk at a bar is not that odd. But, but, but David, he's at a bar. He sees you, brings you with Bob to do the thing. And then you end up, and he had worked on the Ben Stiller show. And then years later, you and Ben worked together a bunch to do with the first thing I met you on was when you did envy with Amy and Ben back in 2001, I think or two or some shit like that. Like, and all those dots just connect. Everything is so, it's so small and connected. It's wild. Yeah. Like if, if anybody ever asked me, like, you know, about my sister last, like,
I have this, my daughter has a friend, what advice would you give them advice for all these young people trying to break into the business or actors? It's just like, go and play the bar down too. Oh, Al's. Play Al's. Al's as much as you can. No, no, just get out there and just do it. You got to just constantly be out there. Like, right? You were, you were so young. How old were you when that happened? 23, 24, our first show. But no, Al's bar was later. I was 27 when we played. It's something like that. 26, 27. I don't know. It's tragic how it's how arbitrary it is, you know, for any of us. I mean, you can think back to the start of, you know, and it's, if we were in the wrong place at that right time, it would have taken longer or maybe not at all. And you
think about all the talented friends that we have that just don't, they have not found that moment of access, you know? Are people championing you? Like, whether it's David seeing you or David Katz, you know, seeing you, seeing that and recognizing that your kid who's got talent, like. No, as I said, the Chris Pratt episode, he was a waiter at the bubblegum shrimp thing in Maui, some casting director or whatever. Casting director saw him there and he was like popcorn shrimp, barbecue shrimp, broiled shrimp, baked shrimp, shrimp gumbo, shrimp of this big. That's an old fashioned Hollywood discovery story. You don't hear those very often. No. The ones that take place at Bubba Shrimp. The casting director just walking into Bubba Gumbo Shrimp. Right. Isn't that the
craziest? It's so, so insane and the likelihood of them having mashed shrimp or shrimp casserole. Oh, there goes Sean again. He loves a good food joke. Oh God, he got this slide right next to the mic today. That's carrot top. Oh, he's got it right next to him today. What else is in the chest, Sean? You guys should do, Sean, I was just thinking that you and Jack should do, because you both are such musical dudes. Anything. We'll do anything. I'd love to see you guys jam out on a musical comedy. Let's do it. That would be fun. That would be cool. Let's do a little, we'll do a, call your Instagram friend up and we'll do like a 10 second or 15 second little musical. Sean just finished this play, Jack. He's going to Broadway soon and he's playing Oscar Levant and
he, to rave reviews, by the way. Thank you. That's really very nice. And it's a play, but he also plays a piano on stage. He's a classically trained pianist. Whoa, true story. Yeah, he knows how to do it all. What's it called? Oscar Levant? It's called Good Night Oscar and it's going to the Broadway. Who wrote that? Doug Wright. He's an amazing Pulitzer Prize winning writer. He actually wrote a movie that's being shot right now with Jamie Foxx and Tommy Lee Jones. Whoa. I just went and saw a play on Broadway. I saw Hugh Jackman and the Music Man. How was it? I want to see that. He was great and it was great and I was really jealous because I always thought that would be my play on Broadway. Okay, so but why, why wouldn't you do it? You have the voice, you have the
stamina. Can you imagine if you were going to see Hugh Jackman and the Music Man there had to do a special announcement. Hugh has come down with COVID. Tonight's performance will be by almost as good, Jack Black. Oh, we got trouble, my friend. Well, we got trouble right here in River City. I'm an enormous Hugh Jackman fan, but let me tell you something. I would love to see you play the Music Man. Yeah. I'm not gonna, I'm not gonna say I'd be better than him, but I would bring some different things. What about Joseph? What's the Technicolor Dreamcoat? Yeah, or Jesus Christ Superstar for that. Yes, Judas. That's the original rock opera. Yeah. A lot of people say, oh, it was Tommy by the Who, but really, Jesus Christ Superstar, I think was first and it was, it was a hard
rock. JC, dude, go a ridge. Wait, Jack, I would be, I would be in the pit playing in the little orchestra, tiny orchestra pit at this dinner theater. And when, when you got to the last song, which was Jesus Christ Superstar, right? And I'd be, I'd have to, I would be playing the piano and they'd be like, the director was like, you know, you can just riff, like just riff on the piano, like bang, go nuts, like rock. And I was like, okay, but I only knew how to riff in classical because I was classical, boy. So it was so rinky-dink, like Jesus Christ, if I could take a superstar, if I could take a hoodoo. Oh, I bet it was great. It was so embarrassingly bad. I know what he's talking about too, the riff, because on the, on the Broadway album, the original Broadway album,
whoever was playing piano was going off on that. Yeah, it's cool. I remember coming over, Jack, I came over to the house a couple of years ago with the boys and you were doing, you're doing your ice bath and you're doing the arctic plunge. Yes. Right. And then we went downstairs and you and the boys rocked out in your basement and Jack's got headphones in there so you don't, he doesn't blow everybody's ear. Yeah, the drums get loud down there. Do they play instruments or kids? Yeah. Sammy, my 15-year-old, has sort of lost interest in it, but now the 13-year-old Tommy, actually just turned 14, he's drumming obsessively. Oh, I really like the drums. Almost too much to where I get concerned, but I'm also just like, good, get obsessed. Yeah. Do play too
much. Do you have them on the electric drums? Dude. Do you have them on the electric drums with the headphones? I spoil them. He's got an electric drum set in his room. He's got the real drum set in the basement because you really can't have a real drum set if you don't have a basement. You have to have an underground soundproof shelter. Getting back to the ice plunge though, Willie, that's something that you do and it's something that I've never understood because I feel like there's got to be damage going on when you drop your bits and pieces in the ice. Jack does it. He keeps the hot tub hot and then he keeps the pool icy cold, right, Jack? Just never heat the pool. It'll get cold enough. I don't want to go in anything cold. I know, Jack. I do the ice. I have
an ice, not ice. I have a cold plunge pool. So it gets even colder than not heating the pool in the winter. Yeah. I get it to like 39 degrees and then I got one degree above freezing. Basically. And then I got the sauna. So I heat up and then I just feel like there's got to be damage going on. The body can't like that kind of shock. Kevin Hart does that cold as balls show. What's that? Where he's in the cold part? It's an interview show where he only interviews people while they're soaking in an ice tub. Is that right? I should do that. I've heard that ice plunge actually is great for anxiety. Yeah. Really? You know what? Here's the other thing. Most, like, anxiety meant all the lot of stuff, but also a lot of physical elements
including, and I'm not saying it's a cure for cancer or anything, but all that stuff, it has to do with inflammation and that cold water reduces inflammation, man. It's so good for you. But don't you think it would be healthier and more safe if you did it slowly? Like, if you just started with room temperature water and you slowly, like a frog in a boiling pot of water, that whatever that saying is, but like, I just think the shock of going in there, isn't there a risk of heart attack? That kind of stress? No. I hear you. No. Like a true American, I'm going to wait for the pill to reduce my inflammation. Yes. That's, you know what it is? It's called Advil. They got it. Yeah. Got it.
Jack, we've taken up way too much of your time, man. Yes, that is. I love it. It's been so great having you. What a dear man. You're the best. Hey, you know, when I first heard you guys, I was like, oh, shit, I should try and get on that show. But then I realized I don't like to do shows because I get too nervous for shows. I only really ever do shows if I have to promote something. But this was always on my bucket list. It's like, I got to do that. Oh, and you are on our list. It should be known. There was a lot of schedule stuff over the last year and a half. We tried to get you a few times because we wanted you. I wanted you big time bad. So you can ask your piece. I fought it, but man, was I wrong? I mean, look, this was great. Ask our mutual peep.
And then there was a lot of sketch. And I had a look you up right when you came on. Jack, we love you. Yeah, Jack, you're the best, man. The feeling is huge. Yeah. Quick plug on the way out the door. No, just kidding. Yeah, quick, quick plug. If you have anybody else you'd like to throw a plug. Yeah. Jack, yes. Love you. Thank you, Jack. Love you. Thanks, buddy. Bye, pal. Say hi to Kyle, please. I will say hi to Kyle. He's going to be jealous that I partied with you guys without you. Let's do a one for all times sake poker game ceremony. Let's do it. Let's do that. All right, cool. All right, Pally. Ciao, ciao. Bye, Jack. He was on my list, Jack. He was on my list. And then we did, for real, have some
sketch issues in the great Louis K, who we all love and adore. Great shout out. But also had a tough time pulling that together because of sketch. And I don't want to throw Louis under the bus again. Oh, you have the same publicist? Yeah. Oh. But he's also, you know, a friend. Right. But if he was a better publicist, probably would have put him on the show earlier. But probably. Listen, Louis K is, you know, he does the best he can. He's still working on getting a full last name, but so he's busy. How great is Jack though? That Jack Black. I'd like more Jack Black in my life. He's such a mega talent, isn't he? Yeah, he is. You know, he's one of those people too, like you can make you laugh with just one word. Like the way he's,
he uses his face or whatever. Or just like a look. I just start grinning as soon as I see him because he's so comfy in his skin and he's just a smooth dude. He's like Ferrell. He falls into that category with me with Ferrell. Well, like, you know, anytime Will walks in the room and you're like, Oh my God. And I feel the same way about Jack. Yeah. He's fantastic. He's been in so many hit movies. Well, and there were a lot more movies that he would be in back. What was it? 10 years ago when comedies, they used to make a lot more comedies. I just don't get why they don't do that. They don't make sitcoms anymore and they don't make comedies studios anymore. They don't make movies anymore. They don't really make movies. Well, let me tell you something. You know what's
doing really well is sci-fi and Jack says he wants to do sci-fi. Yeah, I would love to see Jack do a sci-fi. Jack starring in like a big sci-fi. Yeah, for sure. Yeah. What would you call, what would you call a sci-fi comedy? Let's try to work by into this title of this. Okay. Oh, wow. You're just saying it out loud. Yeah. You're just saying, you know, just identifying it. I think the audience is smart enough. They know we're not, we're not going to sneak up. He's got Kung Fu Panda on Netflix. I just wanted to say for his benefit because he never would say it. But you know what, Jason, back to your point. You know what, Rhymes are a sci-fi. Well, yeah, no, he knows. No, he just said it out loud. Are you just, are you just going to say
bi-fi? No, it's going to say sci-fi. No, no, no, no, no. We have to come up with the title. What is the title of a science fiction comedy? Okay. No, no, hang on. I need, before we get to that, I just need to get to, Sean, you were just going to replace it with bi? Yeah. Yeah. No, he was just going to say sci-fi? Bi-aliens, bi-aliens. Bi-aliens. No, it doesn't work. Bi-aliens. Do better. Bi-aliens. No, how about Star Buyers? No? What? Holy fuck. Star Trek, bye. Oh my god. What the fuck is happening? No, I'm mocking Sean here. Oh, okay. Yeah. Are you? I like sci-bi. Sci-bi? Sci-bi doesn't even make sense. What about you, Will? Yeah,
because it's at the end. Let's have, what's a classic, about 2001 space biology? No? No. How about Bicentennial Man? Oh, yes. Right on with Robin Williams. Okay, there it is. Bicentennial. You guys are the worst. Smart, lost. Smart, lost. SmartList is 100% organic and artisanally handcrafted by Bennett Barbaco, Michael Grant Terry, and Rob Arbjörf. Smart, lost. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.